To illustrate the idea of
a polynomial reduction,
we're going to reduce the problem of
finding an independent set in the graph,
to that of finding a vertex cover.
In the next lesson, we're going to
argue that if P is not equal to NP,
then independent set is not in P,
so vertex cover can't be either.
But that's getting ahead of ourselves.
First, for the benefit of those not all
ready familiar with these problems,
we will state them briefly.
First will consider the independent set
problem and see how it is equivalent to
the clique problem that we talked
about when we introduced the class NP.
Given a graph, a subset of
the vertices is an independent set
if there are no edges between
the vertices in the set S.
For example, these two vertices here
do not form an independent set because
there's an edge between them.
However, these three vertices
do form an independent set
because there are no edges between them.
Clearly each individual vertex
forms an independent set
since there isn't another vertex in
the set for it to have an edge with.
And the more vertices we add, the harder
it is to find new ones to add.
So, finding a maximum independent
set is the interesting question.
Or, phrased as a decision problem,
the question becomes given a graph g,
and an integer k, at most,
the number of vertices, does g
have an independent set of size k?
Note that this problem is in NP.
Given a subset of the vertices, it's
easy to count them to make sure that
there are indeed k, and check that
there are no edits between them.
This problem is so
close to the clique problem that
the two are usually considered as one.
The set is independent in a graph if and
only if there's a clique
in the complement graph.
By the complement graph,
I mean the one where there is no edge
if there was an edge between two
vertices in the original, and
there is an edge if there
wasn't one in the original.
Not having any edges between a set
of vertices in the original graph is
the same as having all the edges among
the vertices in the complement graph.